the acting head of Noah will have a
chance to weigh in on the president's
controversial Hurricane Dorian forecast
today he's speaking to the National
Weather Association in Alabama President
Trump repeatedly and wrongly claimed the
hurricane was a threat to Alabama Noah
was criticized for saying one of the
Weather Service offices should not have
corrected the president Paula Reid's at
the White House Paula why is this coming
up again a good morning Anthony had to
move back to the bureau because the
White House was in lockdown
but even though hurricane durian may
have moved out to see a political storm
continues to rage at NOAA its lead
scientist has vowed to investigate
whether the agency compromised its
scientific integrity by defending
President Trump in the dispute known as
sharpie gait the president is facing new
accusations his administration may have
tried to pressure the National Weather
Service to back up his claims about
Hurricane Dorian the president on
Twitter claimed the storm could hit
Alabama the National Weather Service's
Birmingham office responded saying
Alabama will not see an impact that was
the original chart using a black marker
President Trump doubled down last week
leading to the incident now known as
sharpie gate and according to the New
York Times the Birmingham offices tweet
prompted commerce secretary Wilbur Ross
who oversees NOAA to threaten to fire
top employees at the federal level and
on Friday NOAA seemed to reverse course
in an unsigned statement the agency
appeared to back the president saying
Dorian could impact Alabama the Commerce
Department denied the New York Times
report in a statement saying secretary
Ross did not threaten to fire any NOAA
staff over forecasting and public
statements about Hurricane Dorian on
Monday the director of the National
Weather Service stood by the Birmingham
offices tweet saying it was sent with
one thing in mind Public Safety and
NOAA's top scientists sent a letter to
staffers revealing he is investigating
potential violations that may have
compromised the agency's policies of
scientific integrity the acting head of
NOAA will have a chance to address all
of this controversy later today when he
addresses a meeting of the National
Weather Association in of all places
Alabama Anthony all of the New York
Times is also reporting that the CIA
exfiltrated a high-level Russian
government informant critical to the
investigation into Russian interference
into the 2016 election what information
did that spy provide and why were they
removed well Anthony this informant
provided critical intelligence directly
connecting Vladimir Putin to
interference in the 2016 election the
Kremlin said this morning this person
worked in Putin's office but had no
direct contact with the Russian
President current and former national
security officials tell CBS News that
actually increased media coverage of
Russian election interference led to
growing concerns about the sources
safety and none of the officials we
spoke with believed that this source was
removed in relation to anything
President Trump did but a senior
intelligence official said unequivocally
that President Trump is quote making it
harder to keep sources safe Paula thank
you